Hi! My name is Chloe Marianne, a new animator at Psych2Go. I'm animating this episode for you today. Enjoy!
Dating is rough for everybody
But is being queer an extra hurdle to jump over in the effort to find love?
We at Psych2Go say yes.
There are many unique problems that those in the LGBT community face during their time on the dating scene.
Without further ado, here is a list of eight dating problems the LGBT community faces
Number one: Casual racism
A recent study on gay dating preferences shows that 80% of black men,
79% Asian men and 75% of South Asian men have all endured racism in their efforts to date.
Many people of color also experience fetishization
Black men are messaged in the hopes that they'll be aggressive or masculine
Asian men are often messaged because they might seem cute or submissive
How do women compare? Fairly better, actually.
Queer women are less likely to be affected by ethnicity and more open to interracial dating.
Number two: Fat and femme shaming
The queer community is full of individuals with different body types and gendered energies
This includes some of us who are a little on the skinny side or weigh a few extra pounds,
Or exude some feminine energy.
The unfortunate truth is, gay culture does not deem these traits desirable in our world today
Muscles and manliness went over femininity, which many mistakenly consider subordinate and lesser
Number three: Hook up culture
Believe me, when you're looking for a hook up or a friends-with-benefits type situation, this can be great
This is not to say that there aren't queer people who are searching for a deeper connection
But if you are looking to get to know someone before they stick their hands down your pants, this can be extremely frustrating
It's not easy talking to someone you've just met only for them to ask you about your sexual preferences and what your genitals look like
Number four: Not enough fish in the sea
Growing up in an urban cityscape can be the best thing in the world for a queer person looking for options
Whether you're in New York, L.A, Tokyo or London,
There is endless opportunity for you to find the person of your dreams. Not in a city packed with people?
The odds are less in your favor.
It's hard for a queer person in a small town or sparsely populated area to meet potential partners
Don't give up! Dating in a small town does not mean that you're doomed
Number five: Are they even into you?
Sure, there are some common tells that could give us some insight on whether someone is LGBTQ, but
Sometimes the only way to know is to ask
Is she into women or not? Can you get a guy to fall in love with you even though he keeps calling you his bro?
For the LGBTQ community, this is a common obstacle
Number six: Dating while closeted
Let me preface this point by saying that many people choose to keep their sexual identity a secret for a range of reasons
including the preservation of their personal safety
That being said, it is hard to date while you are still in the closet.
It can be mentally and emotionally exhausting to keep the person you love a secret
It can also be just as exhausting for your partner who must help you maintain a double life in order for your relationship to continue
For these reasons, those who date while in the closet may experience relationships strain.
Number seven: Dating with HIV
HIV is still a huge taboo in the LGBT community today.
Modern medicine has come a long way over the past few decades and HIV is no longer a death sentence.
But those who live with HIV positive status are shunned from the dating scene because of this same fear
and the misconceptions many of us have of HIV.
While it is still important to take safety measures, HIV is an obstacle that can be overcome by couples
It is important to remember that people with HIV are not dirty, or
deserving of their status in any way, and it's totally possible to have a healthy,
safe relationship with an HIV-positive individual.
Number eight: Transphobia
Dating can be rough if you're trans.
Trans and non-binary individuals still receive a great deal of harassment in regards to their gender, sex and appearance.
Trans and non-binary people also have the added stress of deciding if, and when to disclose their identity to dates and partners
Many trans people who are simply looking to get to know someone often find themselves fetishized.
Now, keep in mind the LGBT community is diverse, and a few of these problems are directed more to some than they are to others
The first step to solving these problems is awareness.
The LGBT community and its supporters have the ability to shed light on these issues so that they can be met with love and acceptance.
So, what do you think? Are there any problems that we've missed?
Let us know, are there any items on this list that you feel need their own videos?
We at Psych2Go want to hear from you.
Psych2Go has a new section dedicated to LGBT topics. Click on the link below to read more about this list
and other LGBT articles created by our new content writer, Alex!
Don't forget to like, comment and subscribe.
Hey everybody
I just want to give a personal thank you video for you guys for always supporting Psych2Go and making this all possible for us.
Our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible, so that it promotes self awareness, and it helps you guys grow.
However,
We want to make more content for you guys and would love your support and buying one of these bracelets for our partner, Introvert Pallas
Check out the bracelet.
It's pretty cool and it even includes Pluto. The link to purchase will all be in the description below, and I hope you guys have an amazing day.
Bye!